first on CBS mornings we are revealing
simply the best books of the year so far
according to Amazon books they sell a
lot of them they pay attention some of
the books we're talking about today were
published by Simon and Schuster which
happens to be like CBS part of Paramount
Global we're proud of our friends over
there at Simon and Schuster we're joined
Now by Amazon books editorial director
Sarah gellman Sarah you know so much
about books I'm on a late night talk
show
I mean this is great we're gonna have a
list of the 20 best books of the Year
all the way through the year yes perfect
for some reading yes indeed yeah and
we're going to count down the top three
yep so coming in at number three on the
list so number three is a book called
generations and there the author is a
psychology professor and a PhD her name
is Jean twangy and she discovered that
when you were born has a greater impact
on your personality than the family that
raised you which is incredible what you
think about it so she looked at data
from 39 million people and she in this
book shows facts and Trends from the six
living Generations this is full of very
fun facts so facts like I told Vlad this
before 2023 is the luckiest year to be
born because you're past the worst of
the pandemic you get all the Comforts of
modern technology and by the time those
people children are using social media
there will be better regulations in
place there's also a fact that I loved
that in 2019 households headed by
Millennials were making more money than
households that were headed by silence
Boomers or gen xers at the same age
which counts for inflation and all of
the extra dollars were brought in by
women wow the whole segment on this book
all right number two on the list number
two on the list is all the centers lead
by S.A Cosby I have talked about him on
the show before and if you are not
reading him you absolutely should be he
is so good and he gets better with every
book this is a thriller it's a police
procedural that features the first black
sheriff in a small Southern Virginia
town and he's on the hunt for a serial
killer Stephen King actually just
reviewed this book and he said something
in his very eloquent way that the body
counts High and the action just doesn't
stop this is a great Father's Day book
serial killer Father's Day it's like
perfect love you Dad
and the number one best book of the Year
Midway through the year is it's Hello
beautiful and Napolitano I know you're
familiar with this book and was on the
program it's one of Oprah's picks and
this book it's just that good it's going
to be on a lot of best of lists so this
is a book about family it's family that
you're born into family that you marry
into and family that you make and it's
centered around a man named William
who's sort of broken from his childhood
and his relationship with a woman named
Julia who's one of four sisters in uh in
a very close-knit town and family in
Chicago now these aren't just personal
favorites how did you put this list
together they're not personal favorites
although hello beautiful is my favorite
book of the year I'm gonna put that out
there but this is a full team effort so
I lead a team of editors and our job is
curating books in the Amazon bookstore
so think of about when you walk into a
bookstore and there are staff picks so
we're the staff we are there we are is
that you in the floral that's me in the
floral I know easily recognized surprise
shocking so we basically we're a team of
Book Lovers We're The Feisty group and
yeah we're feisty
um and we we have a lot of opinions what
are you thinking right now I'm not
suggesting that I'm not happy there I
don't agree but we respectfully disagree
we come up with a list every month of
the best books of the month and then for
mid-year we look at the books January
through June we narrow it down to top 20
and when we have 20 books we get in a
room together which is what those photos
show and we call it the smackdown and we
will get out over where the book should
fit on the list and this is not it's not
based on sales not based on ratings it's
books that we love and that we wanted
customers to be introduced to and we ask
ourselves is there something on this
list for everyone it's not meant to be
highbrow it's not meant to be low brow
it's just it should hit a wide swath of
readers everyone should find something
they love on this list bang in the nose
not high brow not low brow uh I love it
thank you very much Sarah Gilman
appreciate you every time you're on this
is a full list of Amazon's best books of
the year so far head to CBS mornings on
Twitter Facebook or Instagram
[Music]